Các bạn có việc nộn dựa chương ngày hôm nay, xíu bảo ra khá xa vẫn duy trí cường độ mạnh các mời bởi
sẽ trên cấp mời bởi tâm bảo cách đạo lưu dơ của Philippines khoảng 1,000 mấy kilomét
vì thí bác.
Xíu bảo đi ngàn với tâm độ 2,5 kg mấy một dơ.
Dự bảo hỏng tối như hôm nay sẽ đi vào khu vực biển đông,
cho thành cơn bảo xo chính trong nằn này.
Xíu bảo sẽ giữ cường độ cực đại ở cấp mời bài.
Xe trên cấp mời bởi tâm hà mi tư dơ tới.
Xe cến khoảng 3,5% tình chính bảo sẽ tiến vào việc bộ với cường độ cấp 1,5%
giật cấp 1,5% và sự bảo ai ngửa chực tiếp đến tất liền bác bộ và bác trường bộ.
Vùng mua hiểm chính biển trong 2,5% là việc bác với tướng với tâm độ vị bác
phía đông, kích tướng 1,5% đụ kinh đông.
Tổ thuyền nhân chẳng, thoát ra, học là không đi vào vùng mua nhé.